so osha is the occupational safety
and health administration and um the
the dol is the department of labor so
we're just going to go to their facts
page www.oh
coronavirus facts hashtag vaccine
where one of the questions is tiny are
adverse reactions to the covet 19
vaccine recordable on the osha
recordkeeping log
it asks on the on the page the answer is
department of labor and osha as well as
other federal agencies are working
diligently to encourage coven-19
vaccinations
osha does not wish to have any
appearance of discouraging workers from
receiving copit-19 vaccination
and also does not wish to disincentivize
employers vaccination efforts
as a result osha will not enforce 29 cfr
1904's recording requirements
to require any employers to record
worker side effects from covet-19
vaccination
through may 2022 we will reevaluate the
agency's position at that time to
determine the best course of action
moving forward
i've read that like eight times now and
every time i just stunned yeah first
time you read it to me
my jaw literally dropped i i i cannot
believe
i cannot believe i i haven't yet found
an agency
that isn't somehow complicit yeah
right so so just to put it in non-osha
language
they've got some you know 29 cfr 1904
recording requirements
for when employers end up doing harm to
employees they have to report it
but if an employee wants to you know
require or strongly encourage
i don't know about strongly encouraged
but certainly if an employer wants to
mandate vaccination
um and the employee ends up harmed as a
result of the
vaccination the employer doesn't have to
keep track of that they don't have to
keep track of that no one has to know
the federal government's not interested
thank you very much
so i would argue we've seen a lot of
monkeying with the baseline i think
there's a strong argument to be made
this is one more manifestation of it
it's also a manifestation as you say you
can't find the agency that says
no actually this looks different to us
because zero is a special number
right this is a case in which you can't
have an agency breaking ranks
now a question for the rest of us how
the hell does this all work
right i don't know why it is
that nothing makes any sense if you
analyze it in the context of either
public health
or individual health the advice does not
add up from the point of view of doctors
trying to help their patients or public
health officials trying to prevent
the pandemic from continuing i'm not
saying it's causal it does all make
sense if you
modify the objective and you say the
objective is to deliver
as many vaccinations as possible whether
or not they are
medically useful or counterproductive or
whatever it's like we're the borg
something is i mean we're just not
a decision was arrived at for the most
part
i mean no one i know was consulted and
it was just handed down this is a decree
as if from god and there will be no
straying there will be no strength there
will be no strain and
um we're not going to play it on this
show but there is a
recording circulating of a doctor being
effectively
fired for talking to his patients about
what he was
seeing and giving advice vaccine was on
the basis of that
and anyway i will make it available
someplace
it's a fairly long you know 20 minute
recording or something like this but
anyway
i don't know how this all works and
frankly i don't know
yes i can say none of this is consistent
with the hypothesis that the thing in
charge whatever it is whatever it's
nature emergent
or a cabal or whatever it is not
consistent with
health it is consistent with the
delivery of vaccines at all costs
i cannot say that that's actually what's
driving it's possible there is a third
hypothesis that is not on the table that
we haven't thought of yet
if that hypothesis exists i'd love to
hear it yeah but
damn in the absence of that hypothesis
this just looks like
a headlong rush into a
giant novel vaccine experiment
with no thought to what happens
if this is harmful yeah
no thought no stopping condition how can
that be
no stopping condition exactly
you